comment vous allez aujourd'hui reçoivent
nos sujets super intéressant on va se
parler d'apple on va parler d'astuces on
va savoir comment déverrouiller son
iphone avec son astre parce que jusqu'à
présent ça n'était pas possible c'était
même une galère absolue et plus j'ai
reçu plein de produits super intéressant
chez apple on va en parler tout ça tout
de suite vous allez voir sujet vraiment
passionnant on reprend l'histoire par le
commencement je sais pas si vous êtes
dans l'écosystème apple si vous avez un
iphone si vous avez un ibook macbook air
macbook pro est une apple watch je vous
explique l'histoire
jusqu'à présent si vous étiez l'heureux
possesseur d'un macbook comme moi
macbook pro et d'une apple wedge vous
pouviez déverrouiller votre ordinateur
très facilement avec ici il est fermé
j'ouvre macbook
hop je sens les libérations et j'ai un
petit message macbook pro déverrouiller
donc ça c'est vachement bien ça c'est
une innovation s'il ya peu et que je
trouve super intéressant et que
j'utilise au quotidien avec une
association ordinateur montre c'est
vraiment l'idée de l'écosystème apple et
il nous manquait une fonctionnalité
tellement importante aujourd'hui pouvoir
déverrouiller avec ça alors on va
repartir un peu dans l'histoire on peut
déverrouiller son smartphone grâce à la
reconnaissance de son visage ça
s'appelle faille side by side 10 à 20 h
bien c'est une innovation d'apple ce que
vous avez c'est que vous avez une caméra
infrarouge qui connaît le visage qui
envoie plein de points de partout et qui
va pouvoir démarrer qu'à voir
déverrouiller votre smartphone dès lors
qu'il reconnaît votre visage est donc
assez gabon vous connaissent eye-fi
saïdi je veux pas vouloir faire la
complète vous prenez pas nouveau mais tu
es comme ça il reconnaît déverrouille
vous pouvez y aller et en avant guingamp
c'est pratique sauf qu'avec le masque
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus possible
veut donc dire que dès lors que vous
êtes dans un bureau au travail dès lors
que vous avez avec des gens autour de
vous car vous êtes dans la rue qu'à du
monde et vous avez levesque
vous ne pouvez pas déverrouiller
facilement et vous ne pouvez plus
poursuit-il cette innovation qui
s'appelle faith heidi alors tous les
possesseurs de smartphone qu'on ait
capteur d'empreintes digitales je veux
dire c'est laurent grosse revanche l'aïe
sont très heureux mais ceux qui ont des
iphone et bien ils sont un peu embêtés
jusqu'à aujourd'hui parce qu'à peut-elle
lancé une nouvelle mise à jour ses aïeux
et 14.5 est parfait faire cette nouvelle
mise à jour est bien pâle à faire pas
mal de choses et notamment de
déverrouiller à son smartphone grâce à
son masque alors oui et donc de la même
manière qu elle faire avec votre macbook
il vous faut une approche vous êtes
obligés d'avoir votre monde connecté
sinon ça ne marchera pas je vous montre
le fonctionnement c'est exactement la
même chose alors on se fait avec deux
caméras
je mets mon masque de zorro
et là hop il était atteint il ne voit
pas je pose la montre la jeune et face à
lui là il a reconnu et voulu marque bien
déverrouiller ici il a déverrouillé
grâce à votre montre hélas mon iphone et
déverrouiller et là j'ai accès à tous
alors effectivement j'ai mon masque donc
l'idée c'est de venir couple et je pense
que lui il analyse imparfaite de votre
visage il doit reconnaître une partie du
visage et tout le reste y voit que ces
hommes se trouvent et qui est un masque
ça veut donc dire que grâce à votre
montre qu' elle est certifiée parce
qu'elles étaient déverrouillées parce
que votre smartphone et elle est
verrouillée
parce qu'avant vous n'aviez pas
justement ce masque vous l'avez
déverrouiller soit grâce au code soit
grâce à votre connaissance de visage
avec faith heidi ça veut donc certifier
que votre montre a été déverrouillés par
vous donc quelque part lorsque vous
n'aviez pas votre masque vous avez des
livres ou des smartphones qui a permis
de déverrouiller votre montre et de
l'activé donc maintenant que vous êtes
masquer votre montre a dit non non c'est
bien cette même personne qui m'a
toujours au bras et au poignet puisque
le possesseur de l'apport enlevé qu'elle
s'est pas retrouvé verrouillé
donc je reconnais bien que même si le
scan état parfait c'est bien cette
personne là qui a dérouillé donc je
valide voilà la logique alors cette
logique elle est intéressante déjà parce
qu'on a tous des masques brûlé mais même
si demain on a plus de masques on peut
imaginer qu'apple concert ça ça veut
dire que vous êtes dans la rue vous êtes
en hiver il fait très froid vous avez
une écharpe il y aura une reconnaissance
un parfait de votre visage mais malgré
tout on pourra déverrouiller donc ça
c'est sympa j'aime bien casser le
premier point est le deuxième point qui
est super intéressant c'est au niveau de
la confidentialité
regardez vous venez ici dans votre
iphone coucou tout le monde vous allez
ici dans vos paramètres que vous avez
donc confidentialité qui est planqué
juste en bas et une nouvelle nouvelle
truc qui est super bien ce situe aussi
dans suivi et dans suivi vous pouvez
demander à ce que vous veniez autoriser
les demandes de suivi des apps alors par
défaut cds cochet c'est à vous de venir
le coach et je vous conseille plus plus
plus devenir l'actionner ça veut dire
quoi
ça veut dire que dès lors qu'une
application voudra vous suivent dès lors
qu un tracking et bien et devrait
valider vous manuellement ça évitera
donc que des applications vous suivent
de manière complètement invisible
et vous ne le sachiez pas donc ça c'est
bien ça va dans le bon sens je trouve ça
vraiment chouette donc ça c'est vraiment
ces deux groupes pour que je voulais
mettre en avant mais surtout le fait de
déverrouiller son smartphone avec son
masque c'est vachement bien alors il ya
d'autres trucs qui sont arrivés chez
apple
regardez il ya plein de nouvelles choses
il ya déjà un nouvel iphone qui arrivait
de les déverrouiller jeu les hommes
boxaient surtout riche d'ailleurs venir
rejoindre mais le lien de la chaîne tout
en bas dans la description qui ne voit
pas ce que j'en ai parlé sur twitter et
je voulais montrer et se produit là il
est super canon je trouve très jolie
c'est l'iphone 12 mail i-mode violée en
couleur violette il ya d'autres couleurs
qui existent moi je trouve vraiment
super sympa très jolie tous les côtés
d'yves mais nous ce que vous en pensez
bien évidemment en bas en commentaire et
pur d'aller attaquer le rpac c'est super
bien pourquoi parce que ça vous permet
et bien de retrouver vos objets
extrêmement facilement pour faire c'est
très simple vous avez votre applications
localisées qui est juste là vous cliquez
dessus alors je vais pas vous le montrer
parce que ça vous permettra de voir où
je suis j'ai pas forcément de suite mais
l'idée c'est que ça va vous dire
les clés sont pas très loin et lorsque
vous les avez perdu je peux émettre en
sont déjà il ya un petit sens assez en
plus résistants à l'eau imaginez par
exemple la sémec les gpo mais mes clés
et bien j'active le mode perdu et ça me
permettra grâce à tous les réseaux
d'appareils ios qui sont connectés ça va
être un iphone ça va être un ipad et
compagnie est bien de pouvoir le
localiser alors il faut savoir des
appareils tiers qui vont récupérer les
informations et bien eux n'auront pas
accès aux coordonnées du propriétaire
mais ça tout ça sera cryptée mais vous
vous saurez est bien tel appareil était
localisé à tel endroit
ça permettra de retrouver très
facilement donc ça s'est super bien je
vous en parle d'ici quelques jours on va
se faire un point complet on va se faire
une belle mise en situation
j'aime bien cet hommage et je trouve
très cool très probable voilà il ya
plein de petits accessoires avec pour
venir les accrocher que ce soit sur un
jeu de clés que ce soit sur un vélo sur
un parapluie mais maintiendra t il ya
plein de solutions
voilà ce que je voulais partager avec
vous aujourd'hui donc plein de
nouveautés chez apple bien évidemment le
fait de pouvoir déverrouiller ça c'est
très chaud à 10,3 vous ce que vous en
pensez en bar commentaire fait cette
mise à jour il ya une mise à jour à
faire sur ios 14
eyeos 14 points 5 sur votre iphone et
vous avez également une mise à jour à
faire sur votre apple watch pour pouvoir
déverrouiller très facilement avec votre
masque voilà tout ce que j'avais à vous
dire pour aujourd'hui
des bisous de l'amour à bientôt pour lé
soin de vous et n'oubliez pas mais moi
je ne sors tout aussi bientôt caoutchouc